So there is a problem with the centralized barrier.
That is that when, the count has become 0, if
these guys immediately are allow-, allowed to go on
executing before the count has been reset to N, then
they can all reach the next barrier and then
they fall through. And that is a problem. So the
key thing to do To avoid this problem, or to
overcome this problem, is to make sure that the threads
that are waiting here, they don't leave the barrier before
the count has been reset to N. Right? So they're all
waiting here for the count to become zero, and once
the count has become zero they are ready to go, but,
we don't want to let the go yet. We want to let
them go only after the count has been reset to N.
So what we're going to do is, we're going to add another
spin loop here. And that is, after they recognize that the
count has become 0, they're going to wait till the count
is not N yet. And so this ordering of these two
statements is very important, obviously. So, we want to wait till
the count has become 0. At that point we know that
the value is over, but we want to make sure that
the counter has been reset to N by the last guy,
and once that has been done, then we are ready to
go on executing the code that we need to execute til,
til we get to the next barrier. So we solve
the problem with the first version of the centralized barrier,
and that is the counting barrier. By having a second
spindle. That's the problem, right? There are two spin loops
for every barrier in the counting algorithm, and ideally, we
would like to have a single spindle. And and that's
the reason that we have this particular algorithm, which is
called sense reversing barrier. If you recall in the counting barrier,
we needed two spinning episodes. The first spinning episode
was When you arrive at the barrier, decrement the count,
and wait for the count to become 0. That's
the first spinning episode. And the second spinning episode to
leave the barrier, what you need to do was
to make sure that the count has become N, right?
Those were the two spinning episodes that were there
in the counting barrier. And in the sense reversal, Barrier,
we're going to get rid of one of those
spinning episodes. The arrival one. We'll get rid of
it. So we don't have to spin on count
becoming zero. And we'll see how that is done.
So what you notice is that in addition
to the count, there is a sense variable, in
the shared variables that we have, we included a
new variable called sense variable that's also shared by
all the processes that want to accomplish a barrier
synchronization. And the idea behind the sense variable is
that the sense variable is going to be true for
One barrier episode, and it's going to be false for
the next barrier. So because we, at most you
have one barrier at a time, and therefore, if
you call this barrier the true barrier, the next
barrier is going to be the false barrier So that's
the way we can identify which barrier we are in at any particular point of
time so far as a given thread is concerned by looking at the sense variable.